Hello everybody my name is Markiplier, and welcome to
[sings] DEATHLIKE
(deep voice) Awakening
Oh GAHH I'm in a book!
OH. DEMON senses your moves!
Oookay!
*Pronounces "push" like "phoush'* Pushhh this button to start the game... I don't know if I wanna "phoush" it
Anyway, I...wait, where's my hands?
My hands here?
My hands on?
No, my hands are not on. Where's my hands?
Ok.  Oh! There I am! Ok.
Uh, thouch it!
THOUCH! Uh-oh...
Alright, so this game...
...promises demons that sense my movement!
which is...
b-oh, I hate it already.
Oh, I-uh, I hate this. Why is one controller still?
Uh-oh.
Ok. Uh, oooh!
Uh, (laughs) it's a Naruto run!
SCOOCH!
Just gotta ROW, ROW, ROW the boat here!
Alright!
(Worried Sounds)
Uh, I gotta find 7 sigils...
So, uh, it's a very Slenderman-esque
(chuckle) I love the rowing of the boat! Kind of like...
[sings tunes about rowing boats]
OH, it's a-oh, I get it!
[Mark making an effort to walk]
Ohhh, that's a clever mechani- Uh-oh.
*Mark goes quiet as a barely audible rustling noise is heard*
uh..UHHHHHH.
I'M NOT MOVING, I'M NOT MO-I'M NOT MOVING!
AH! Oh god!
(First Jumpscare) OOOH, HI, WOAH.
Okay, alright. Don't move, I get it. Alright, I need to not move! I get it! When you tell me to not move, you know...
I don't move. That's what I do. WOW, that was not fun.
DOOPADOOPADOODOODOO. Uh-oh. (rustling sounds)
eeee...
NO.
[Inaudible zoom]
AM I GOOD?
*Sings a variation of "do, did do, do duh do"  in anxious tones*
UH. *rustling noises*
Oh, I hate this.
IIII'M NOT MOVING!
Ah, OK, bye.
HUH...
HUH.
[Even More Singing]
OH, HI...
*worridly* Oh. Hi. Hello
MMkay, bye. See you. Ok, I'm gonna go this way, then...
[Frantic Singing]
I'M SWINGING MY ARMS, I'm gonna swing this one cos...
Don't wanna...Oh. (normal voice) ...cause a ruckus.
Okay, alright...
(weird voice) Alright, I see how it is. OK. Alright. I s-ooh.
OOH, I think I recognise this area from PUBG.
Uh, any sigils in here?
Any sigils I should know about?
Okay, alright.
Well, continuing ON MY WAY...
Just ol' swing arm over here, that's...
that's me. Uh-oh.
Heard somethin'.
But I don' kno' WHAT!
So I'm just gonna keep swing-swonging,
until the DAY is DONE!
ooh, pretty architecture. I lik-OH, the Sistine Chapel! Ok, alright, that makes sense...
(begins sermon) Alright, hear ye, hear ye. *imitates bell clanging*
I have this weird device from the future! Here, watch a shadow puppet.
See, this is Jesus...
and uh...
This is also Jesus.
So, Jesus, and uh, Jesus Two, came here and...
Anyway, imma move on now, before I cause more sacrilege.
And uh, make the ghost angry. (mumbling) Huh, yeah that seems right...
I didn't see a sigil.
So I'm just gonna..
[ Singing]
*Still singing* I'm going thru the woods. Dadadee. I hope I'm facing the right way.
Cause I can't see bloody shithole dicks
*Stops singing* Uh-ooh.
(continues singing) Nothing, it was just my imagiNATION. Walkin' thru the woods and getting really disorientated. Ooh.
*Stops singing as loud rustling noise is heard* Ooh, that's not good.
Uh-oh. My things is vibrating Real GOOD!
Hello?
Hello? (x2)
OK...
Alright...
I don't like that. Where am I?
Where am I facing, by the way? Where am I-oh, I'm completely wrong. Excuse me.
You're over... there. You're THIS TREE. Hi, tree. Maybe if I just dance, like...
That would be enough to suggest (like) some movement?
Cool. That's doing it. Ok.
Get a lil' dance...
This way...
[Singing!]
This is terrifying...
This is awful...
I hate this a lot...
nn, yeah, this is unpleasant!
Ho, boy!
Yeah, this is what I would call very scary!
Ay yi yi yi...
I don't see no goddamn sigils!
I don't even know what the frick-fracking sigils look like!
Uh, oh. Wheatfield.
Nothing good ever happened in a wheatfield!
Ok, alright well this is a change of pace!
Not only in my walking style but in...
Uh, the wheatfield..
I'm going through a wheatfield...
cos that's what I wanted to do!
Ooh. The... FUCK was that?
Bother me during my wheatfield stroll?
Huh?
Someone got a problem with it?
Ok, I'm really gonna go for it. Everybody close your eyes for a bit. It's about to get real weird.
Nah, that's no faster.
(panting sounds)
Row, row, row your boat!
Sailing down the STREAM.
They're ain't a-ooh, hello. They're ain't a-I was about to say, there ain't a sigil to be found, but I think I found a sigil.
Hang on, let's see what's in here.
Sure it'll be a-warm and welcoming and make me feel good about myself. Hello?
Ah. That looks bad.
Ok, I'll just go in and I'll just-
Hang on, I'll just-ooh.
[Ominous Music plays then abruptly stops]
NOPE.
You know, I'm-imma-OH. Hey, a sigil! UH-OH, I bl-I blacked out for a second there. Apparently, I got a sigil tho.
What's in here? What's in this bloody box of despair?
Huh? Nothing, hopefully? Ok, well, ther-god, it does not want me to look at that sigil.
(looks at sigil) HUH.
SIGILLLLL. Ok, I got one.
Alright, good for me.
Ok, onto the next one.
Oh, hi. Okay, hi.
Oh, this is a bad thing.
UHHHHHHHHHHHH.
Ok, oh hi.
Hi, hello. I'm not moving.
I'm not moving. I'm not moving. I'm NOT moving.
Oh god, I almost moved.
(Oh Intensifies)
EEEE. *soft rustling noises*
EEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE.
OK, alright.
Everybody hold on.
I'm feeling some vibrations.
Everytime I know it's close, my controller starts vibrating.
That's bad.
The vibrations have stopped. *pauses*
I'm gonna move now
*crunching noise* EEE. Oh, that's me.
K. Oh, hi. Hello.
Oh, you like to scamper, don'tcha?
Oh you like to sc-AAAAAA.
Oh, you're real scampery.
Oh, look a truck.
Reminds me of Slenderman.
EEEEE. AAAAAA.
Oh, it's getting real shaky!
OOOH NOOO.
It's as simple as that.
It's just a stroll in the woods.
That's all it is.
That's all it'll ever be. is that a sigil i think i see oh yeah i bet it is
*rustling sounds that get slightly louder* OHH OHH OHH.
(second jumpscare) NOO! I DIDN'T MOVE! GODDAMMIT!
OH MY GOD.
That is terrifying. That is frick-fracking terrifying. Alright, I'm gonna go one more time (x2) I think I can do this a little better.
Ya gotta follow the road. That's the thing. You have to follow the road.
If you follow the road, you'll have a-woah hey.
You have a much better chance of surviving.
Where am I?
I am in nowhere. I am-
I'm in the void, apparently I-
broke the game! I think.
Ok. Oh, there I am! Ok, there I am!
Ok. So there's the road....
Then, I'm gonna go to the road.
Then, I'm gonna stick onto that road like glue!
No reason to go off the road!
Ain't no reason to get scared.
It's just a simple creature
that's stupid and dumb and probably extremely ugly.
Yup, that's it! That's ALLLLL there is!
OOOOkay...
Alright!
Just me. Alone in the woods.
ALONE.
NOBODY BESIDE ME. JUST ME.
ALL ALONE!
HERE, ALONE!
That's me alright.
OK. Ooh, what are you?
I can't read that but it looks like something from...
PUBG as well!
ooh [rustling sounds]
hiii...
hello
Where'd you go?
*long silence minus soft rustling noises*
kaaay...
*another long silence*
kay
alright
Gonna GO! Up the stairs!
Into the building where I don't think you can follow me and OH LOOK A SIGIL!
ooh
*soft footstep-like noises in background*
uh oh
*silence*
My controllers are shaking up a storm!
Get that-I'm looking at you. I'm looking at you SO GOOD!
UHHHHHH...
BONK! Ok,
ONE! Six more to go!
Sonuvabitch. YOU DON'T SCARE M-Oh, you scare me. Ok, alright.
OH NO...
(quietly) i'm not movin'
OK, bye! See ya!
(breaks down) UUUUUUUAAHHHH!
I WENT BLIND! UH,
UUAAHH! OK, just gonna skedaddle away!
Skedaddling away!
IMMA SKEDADDLING AWAY!
That's what I do and that's what I say! IMMA Skedaddling away!
Wheehoo! Oh whaahoo!
Ah, yes, I've entered the area of the dead trees! It's awfully pleasant for me. I'm super happy about how they're all dead, it reminds me of what I'm gonna be in a few seconds!
Oh, is that a graveyard? I hope-oh, I pray!
Oh, I WISH UPON A STAR THAT IT'S A GRAVEYARD!
OOOOHHH, all my prayers have been answered! It's a graveyard!
O frabjous day! Callooh, callay!
*Unspecified eerie noise in background* Oh, I don't like those sounds but you know what? It's alright.
Can I go in here? Is there a sigil in here? Anybody? No sigil? Really?
Really? No sigi-oh, there it is-there she blows!
Come here, you! Come to papa!
Hey, how's it going? You're doing great. OK. TWO! I GOT TWO!
*Eerie noise slowly amplifies*  Yeah, ok you can stop that any moment now.
The moaning's really not becoming of you.
*Eerie noise dies away* Ah, really swing-swonging it now!
Ooh, this feels natural.
This feels like natural movement.
Ah, nice horse! How's your dick?
Nice balls on you. Oh nothing? Ok, nevermind. I was lying about all that.
i just complemen' peop- ughh
*Mark makes an odd, gurgling noise*
OK, alright. Nothing here. Alright! ON MY WAY! OUT THE DOOR WITH MOOOREEE
I'm gonna go around the perimeter until I loop back. That's what imma do.
Uh, oh it's the truck!
The one I died at before! Remember that one guys?
Oh yeah that was FUN!
Dying here, oh look no sigil either. You know what, that's fine.
Didn't really want one anyway.
Lemme check the truck, maybe it's in ther-oooh.
There she blows!
I see you!
Hang on! Gotta really skedoodle around this thing, and-
Uh, schwumpo.
Ah, it looks like a truck-o-domider, I like that. Ok, skooodellidoo.
AH! [scary rustling sounds]
uhhh
no
i ain't movin'
nah
oh
hoh...Just gonna go this way! OH BOY! OH I LOVE THIS!
UH. OH. OOOH. [more rustling noises]
ooh
*rustling noises that go on for a few seconds then stop completely*
(High-pitched noises from Mark)
(Third jumpscare) OOOOH GODDAMMIT! AH FUCK YOU!
Ah Shit. Anyway, that is Deathlike-
-Awakening. That is really fun, good mechanics there. Very scary, the whole not moving thing. That's really nice, so
Thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you thought of this one down in the comments below. I might finish this one.
But it is a little disorienting. A little nauseating.
Uh, not something that you can play for super extended periods of time, but-
-still, very scary stuff. So thank everybody so much for watching, and as always, I'll see you...in the next video. BYE BYE!
*outro music*